anyone give me the question I bear with
me my voice is out we do questions
unhelpful voice with Bobby
kalila and the little child alien this
question is from our friend Iago
sorry guys Gilbert's voices out of
commission everyone yeah good this is
for everyone but mainly Bobby hey Bobby
so I know that you smoke a lot and eat
junk food and don't like to exercise my
dad is simple why don't they put it man
I don't agree yeah yeah I I can't
understand what you're saying I mean I'm
an actor I'm a trained eye to I can do
this then you go higher though try we
try it all right Bobby so I know you
smoke a lot eat junk food it don't like
to exercise my dad is similar he said
his 60s ad has diabetes and it's
extremely difficult to motivate him to
get healthy I've noticed that more of my
mom nags him to exercise eat well more
he doesn't do it in spite of her I'm
sure kalila is experiencing this I can
get him to exercise if there is some and
point we're heading towards but that's
about it
coming from your perspective what do you
think is the best way to motivate you to
exercise / eat well and be healthy or is
it totally a lost cause now that you're
set in your ways we can all I don't
think of this I think that listen if if
it's all it depends on the individual
it's like if he doesn't if he knows if
that it's gonna kill him he should know
that like I know cigarettes are gonna
kill me
hmm I know it I'm gonna die from it I
think there's a part of it as accepted
that you know so it's like you know it
depends on how he if he wants to live
he'll change and if he doesn't want to
then he won't this can be one of the
most frustrating positions to be in like
when someone you love all you want is
for them to be healthy and happy and
live as long good life and you can't
control that is such a frustrating like
I feel Bianca right now at six
it's inferior you have somebody in your
life that yeah well I sometimes I feel
like that with my boyfriend like he
I love them and maybe this is mean being
I don't I don't know I know it's like I
don't he's private but I know he is you
know I just there are certain ways he
could be healthier and I try and it's
hard because I'm not health that all
that healthy either but it's like see
Dave and I have the same body yeah okay
we have the same nails we do we bite our
nails yeah he but I don't know but he
definitely like bites if I feel skin to
the bull up till those blood yeah he
likes to make himself leave yeah yeah
and I mean it just can't be good I know
but when I look at David I look at a Jew
Jewish version of me I do yeah
when I look at him like we're the same
type we're hilarious caught you know to
us we're hilarious right we're creative
but we look like we look weird
physically we've accepted that over the
years I'm not gonna be [ __ ] Brad Pitt
ever so what do you do do you nag him do
you do you it's right how do you trick
him yeah have you given up or did you
it's a little bit of everything like I
try to be one thing that helps is like
being playful and sweet about it instead
of being nagging like cuz that nagging
and being nasty never works you I I
finally you have to come at it from like
a place of love and so in a fun way even
though that might seem hard like I don't
know like a game that that I like
sometimes if taste like I really want
dessert and like I know I do too but I'm
really in my mind I'm like [ __ ] that's
all I want is ice cream and cookies
right now but I'm trying to you know be
an actress and so I'll say like okay if
we just go to bed if you just go to bed
and wait 30 minutes cookies will appear
ya know like it just like magically
though I'll bring you because I know
he'll fall asleep yeah yeah I mean
that's so embarrassing works though but
but I don't I think maybe like just
trying to get someone exercise maybe
like getting them a fit better like my
sneakers or you know oh yeah that
doesn't work with them yeah I asked him
the same question Bianca is asking which
is what what will it take for you to you
know consider a lifestyle change and
he's like I need a doctor to tell me I
am completely unhealthy and that I'm
probably gonna die this way so I was
like okay I'll make you a doctor at this
appointment doctor basically told him
that nothing has changed also be so
frustrating for you as your nurse it's
uh it's but then you you know what my
dad was similar he just like he liked
what he wanted you know he wanted to eat
what he wanted yeah there's really no
it's hard I understand it you know like
I bacon a lot and I know that how bad
bacon is like it's processed me it's
read me it's so bad for you and I don't
know Bacon's the best I just say good
when it's in front of me I can't not eat
it so it's I get it
[Music]